quick story about George Zimmerman
initially after George Zimmerman was
acquitted in the killing of Trayvon
Martin there were a number of run-ins
with police police were called because
of alleged domestic violence against
this girlfriend whole bunch of different
police interactions and then things got
very very quiet until now George
Zimmerman was apparently punched in the
face at a Sanford Florida restaurant
over the weekend and witnesses say he
was bragging about having killed Trayvon
Martin Channel nine obtained the 911
call that was made and we will put the
transcript up on the screen for you the
911 dispatcher is saying who started the
argument Zimmerman saying he recognized
me he told me he was going to kill me he
told me he'd expletive shoot me and he
punched me in the face this man just
punched me in the face
the dispatcher saying is he's still
there Zimmerman saying yup he said he's
going to kill me you need to send like
three or four cops Zimmerman later
claimed that he was explaining to people
sitting at the table that he had shot
Trayvon Martin and self-defense when a
large man approached and said you're
bragging about that before reportedly
punching George Zimmerman in the face
now in this little incident Zimmerman is
considered the victim but when witnesses
were spoken to by authorities they said
no no Zimmerman just came over and
started bragging about killing the
unarmed teen they overheard Zimmerman
reportedly say to some other person I
love your tattoos my name is George
Zimmerman you know the guy who killed
Trayvon Martin and witnesses say he then
proceeded to show his ID this is weird
Louis you have some tattoos have you
ever provided ID when you show people
your tattoos or explain them to people
this is he thinks he's a celebrity yeah
well in a way he sort of is an infamous
one I suppose but what this isn't the
first time we've heard that he brags
about this regularly I mean it's his
claim to fame I'm starting to suspect
that George Zimmerman is not a great guy
just now yeah yeah it only took him
killing an unarmed teenager in a
confrontation he created calling
President Obama a baboon publicly
retweeting image of Trayvon Martin's
corpse posting nude pictures of his
ex-girlfriend without her consent on the
Internet publicly declaring that his
ex-girlfriend is a
[ __ ] for effing a quote dirty Muslim on
social media partnering with a Muslim
free gun shop to sell Confederate flag
prints that he made getting arrested for
pointing a shotgun at his girlfriend and
then again for throwing a wine bottle at
his girlfriend allegedly and then
arrested for battery of an officer after
the officer tried to arrest an underage
kid that Zimmerman brought into a bar
years and years ago maybe these stories
are all just wrong maybe you've got the
wrong idea
and this is just the media painting a
bad picture of a a really great guy I
maintain we have not heard the last of
George Zimmerman let's take a break
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s